y aquí tenemos la gráfica de cuando y es
igual a gdx y me gustaría que pensáramos
en el límite de eje x cuando x se
aproxima a 5 ya hemos hecho esto muchas
veces entonces vamos a pensar en lo que
pasa con ge de x cuando x se aproxima a
5 desde la derecha y desde la izquierda
aquí podemos ver que eje x se aproxima a
menos 6 conforme x se acerca a 5 desde
la derecha entonces gp x se aproxima a
menos 6 así que una estimación razonable
basándonos en lo que podemos ver en esta
gráfica es que conforme x se aproxima a
5 gt x se aproxima a menos 6 ahora es
importante que se den cuenta de que g de
5 es igual a un valor diferente pero el
objetivo de este vídeo es simplemente
apreciar todo lo que hace un límite un
límite
únicamente describe el comportamiento de
una función conforme se aproxima a un
punto no nos dice exactamente qué es lo
que
pasa con ese punto que en este caso es g
de 5 y nos dice mucho sobre el resto de
la función o la gráfica por ejemplo
podríamos construir diferentes funciones
en las que el límite de x se aproxima a
5 pero los límites son muy diferentes
por ejemplo podríamos decir que el
límite de fx cuando x se aproxima a 5 es
igual a menos 6 y podemos construir una
función f x que se vea muy diferente ag
de x de hecho los invito a que pause en
el vídeo e intenten hacer lo mismo y si
tienen papel para graficar simplemente
dibujen y bueno la clave aquí es que el
comportamiento de la función cuando x se
aproxima a 5 desde ambos lados es decir
desde la derecha y desde la izquierda
tiene que acercarse a menos 6 por
ejemplo una función que se ve así voy a
dibujar una f de x que se ve así y se
define aquí y luego hace algo como esto
funcionaría porque conforme nos
acercamos desde la iss
pierda nos aproximamos a menos seis y
conforme nos acercamos desde la derecha
nos aproximamos a menos seis ahora
también podríamos tener una función como
ésta supongamos que este es el límite de
hd x cuando x se aproxima a 5 y es igual
a menos 6 y podríamos tener una función
como ésta que tal vez se define aquí
arriba pero después tenemos un círculo
aquí y continúa o tal vez no está
definida en ninguno de esos valores y
hasta acá se define por todos los
valores de x mayores o iguales a 4 y
después continúa hacia menos 6 entonces
observen todas estas funciones cuando x
se aproxima a 5 todas tienen el límite
definido ya igual a menos 6 pero todas
estas funciones se ven muy diferentes
otra cosa importante es que muchas veces
voy a borrar esto
muchas veces nos piden que encontremos
los límites cuando x se aproxima a un
cierto valor por ejemplo cuando x se
aproxima a 5 eso es muy interesante
porque en este punto existe una
discontinuidad y podemos llevar el
límite a un número infinito de puntos
para esta función de aquí podemos decir
que el límite dgt x cuando x se aproxima
a 1
cuál sería pausa en el vídeo y traten de
resolverlo ustedes primero ok vamos a
ver cuando x se aproxima a 1 desde el
lado izquierdo parece ser que nos
aproximamos a este valor y conforme x se
aproxima a 1 desde el lado derecho
parece que nos aproximamos a este valor
así que esto sería igual a g de 1 esto
es igual a g de 1 y esa sería una
conclusión razonable al analizar esta
gráfica y si estimamos que g de 1 es
aproximadamente igual a menos 5.1
5.2 menos 5.1 podemos encontrar el
límite de gx cuando x se aproxima a p
entonces pi se encuentra por aquí y
cuando x se aproxima a pi desde la
izquierda nos acercamos a este valor que
de hecho se encuentra muy cerca de este
y conforme nos acercamos desde la
derecha nos acercamos a este valor y
nuevamente en este caso esto será igual
a g de pi y aquí no tenemos ninguna
discontinuidad así que podemos construir
muchas funciones diferentes que tendrán
el mismo límite en un punto y para una
función dada podemos sacar el límite en
muchos puntos diferentes de hecho en un
número infinito de puntos porque es
importante mencionar que muchas veces
nos acostumbramos a ver límites
únicamente en aquellos puntos en los que
ocurre algo extraño